soon as you [ __ ] watch it too fast
you start doing dumb [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
the whole thing the reason there's so
many [ __ ] crypto and cannabis and
social media experts is people chase
friends not what they're good at or like
people are chasing the next fast thing
and so the question i want to know is
why do you want it so fast not because i
don't like the ambition and bravado i
[ __ ] actually love it i live it it's
i don't want them to put a time frame
because that leads to anxiety you have
to understand i don't give a [ __ ] about
the end goal i care about the process
the enjoyment of doing it wouldn't you
rather guarantee millionaire shift by 36
than by doing long-term marathon running
versus doing a bunch of [ __ ] sprints
that guarantees never having it and i
promise you a funny thing happens to
your self-esteem when you're 31 and not
a millionaire because you've been
chasing fast [ __ ] cash and you're now
six years removed from not hitting your
goal your self-esteem starts [ __ ]
with your head